[Aplausos]
cuál es tu sueño si si tu sueño lo que
te inspira lo que te motiva con lo que
despiertas cada día lo que hace que te
hierva la sangre tus anhelos
[Música]
tus grandes sueños
cuáles son
si has tardado más de estos segundos en
traerlos a tu mente y a tu corazón o muy
probablemente has dejado tus sueños
guardados ahí en un cajón o escondiditos
para que no se pierdan para que no estén
en riesgo o bien quizá no te has
planteado los sueños correctos cuando yo
era pequeño tenía dos sueños el primero
de ellos
estaba sentada junto a mí en kínder la
niña más bonita del salón y dije
me voy a casar con ella
le robe el anillo de compromiso a mi
mamá y al día siguiente en el recreo le
propuse matrimonio
la niña tomó el anillo y sin decirme
nada se fue al día siguiente la mamá le
habla a la mía y le dice oye creo que tu
hijo le propuso matrimonio a la mía a
pesar de mi desilusiones del amor
seguí creyendo en él y por ahí de 3º de
primaria en una kermés
me di cuenta que a pesar de lo doloroso
que había sido mi primera experiencia
dije ahora lo voy a hacer distinto y
bien la más guapa de 3º de prepa y en
medio de la carm es' le dije te quieres
casar conmigo me dijo si realmente yo
era el más feliz del mundo fuimos al
registro civil nos casamos y después de
sacarme no la volví a ver
claro que en sueños
que no se materializan y que incluso
puede ser que los dejemos en nuestro
pasado otro más
yo de chico le dije a mi madre con mucha
convicción mamá yo voy a jugar fútbol
voy a formar parte de la selección
nacional y voy a meter un gol en el
estadio maracaná de brasil se lo decía
con tal convicción y todos los días
tienen madre estaba seguro de lo que lo
iba a lograr y ustedes podrán decir luís
fernando es un gran futbolista y triunfo
en ello no no soy ni un medallista ni un
gran deportista ni un emprendedor es más
no sé ni por qué me invitaron aquí soy
una persona común y corriente que te
quiere transmitir cuáles son las claves
de estos sueños un sueño que podría
verse como una llave que nos abre la
puerta a la disrupción y a la innovación
claro que yo nunca fui a pruebas de
fútbol este sueño lo dejé olvidado y por
ahí en un mochilazo con unos amigos
estuvimos en brásil y cualquier
cualquiera que fue mi primer destino en
el maracaná yo entré a la cancha en un
tour como cualquier otro que paga por
hacerlo y de pronto pues unos policías
obviamente no te dejaban pasar
yo al querer entrar por el mesón o de
ninguna forma
pero es que yo estoy grabando un
cortometraje para méxico casi le dijo
que no sabe quién es iñárritu y del toro
son mis tíos
aproveche el primer descuido que tuve
para con una pelota de fútbol arrancar y
corriendo en la cancha del maracaná como
cualquier mortal y meter un gol pero
cuando lo estaba haciendo
dije acaso este era mi sueño en la vida
acaso
hemos dejado de preguntarnos hacia dónde
vamos y por qué lo hacemos claro que los
sueños son para tenerlos aquí en las
manos a flor de piel y construirlos día
a día pero no sólo de una cuestión
idealista
y tampoco es que hay una fórmula mágica
para hacerlo pero lo primero que te
quiero invitar a reflexionar es que hoy
mucho se habla de éxito
de plenitud de felicidad de
trascendencia pero cómo construirlo
primer paso todo parte de una decisión
la decisión para querer hacer las cosas
para pensar de una manera distinta pero
llevarlo en consecuencia una decisión
que emana del fondo de ti
toda decisión debe tener un claro
propósito de saber hacia dónde vas y
este propósito tiene que ser algo
retador algo motivante algo digno de
grandeza dejar estos sueños baratos por
sueños que valgan la pena
pero aquí viene lo más complicado de la
fórmula y es que se requiere talento
para ello y el talento no solo como un
don que se recibe sino como un esfuerzo
que se puede construir día a día y hace
valido esa decisión
yo quisiera tomar una analogía
y
tomaré a la luz del liderazgo algo que
mucho mucho se ha hablado es más me
parece que estemos prostituido de más la
palabra hoy pareciera que cualquiera
puede ser un líder o todo es liderazgo
pero quisiera que lo viéramos con una
nueva nueva luz un nuevo enfoque y
quisiera tomar los atributos de un
animal poderoso de un ave ejemplar
incluso un icono de nación es un animal
una vez que es poderosísima pero claro
que comienza siendo un polluelo muy
pequeño quiero hablarles del águila pero
ojo no cualquier tipo de águila no no un
águila de calidad un águila en plenitud
y claro que en esto
pues podríamos encontrar atribuciones
personales a la figura del águila
y quiero hablarte de tres de ellas
todas águila posee una cualidad de
visión de lealtad y de reinvención
y empezaré con esta la capacidad para
reinventarse un polluelo que como lo
veíamos frágil e indefenso tiene que
volar del nido y es su propio padre en
su propia madre quien lo avienta sin
saber sin saber volar híjole yo lo veo
así es como si a mi hija de seis meses
la agarrara de la cuna la bajara y le
diga ahora le tomas la ruta 10 para que
te vayas a la escuela y que te vaya muy
bien claro que el águila asume los
primeros retos
desde los primeros días de su vida
no esperemos a reinventarnos cuando
llegue la última etapa de nuestra vida o
cuando sean los obsoletos o cuando las
crisis nos dominen o cuando sean los
constantes problemas los que nos llenan
día a día la capacidad de reinventarse
en un líder es la forma de dar una
mirada nueva al día a día
en la águila es experto en cazar y para
eso tiene una visión poderosísima como
pocos animales como pocas aves incluso
civilizaciones antiguas creían que el
águila era el único animal que podía ver
de frente al sol
como estamos viendo en nuestros sueños
nuestros sueños nos opacan nos da miedo
verlo de frente la visión es fundamental
para toparnos con esos sueños para
convertirlos en realidad
esa visión del liderazgo se compone en
el día a día es curioso ver que un
experto de la casa como es el águila que
no hay quien con su visión puede hacerlo
mejor solo lleva a cabo el 30 por ciento
de sus ataques con éxito para cazar esto
sería como si fueras con un doctor con
un cirujano que te va a operar del
corazón y te diga pues
siete de cada diez pacientes se me
mueren pero no es usted el experto y
vaya que lo soy pero mi porcentaje de
éxito es el 30 por ciento y yo le decía
en cuenta que me gusta el fútbol es como
es como si fuera el cruz azul y llegarás
a una final más estos hombres han
formado una resiliencia tremenda que ya
ha perdido el temor al dolor al
sufrimiento
hay que intentarlo una y otra y otra vez
reinventarnos requiere de una gran
capacidad tener una visión que esta
apuesta fija en un objetivo claro en un
propósito por lo tanto un verdadero
líder no se compone solo de las
decisiones que toman sino también del
propósito claro que tiene con esa visión
y finalmente la lealtad que tiene un
águila no solo porque es un ave que
cuando elige una pareja lo hace para
toda la vida
no solo porque en medio de la tormenta
no se mueve de su nido para dejar
desprotegidos a sus crías a sus huevos
la lealtad con tus sueños con tus
convicciones con quién eres es lo que te
permitirá echar raíces en un verdadero
liderazgo pero entonces quiero relevante
de todo este asunto
hay que reconocer que hoy en día
enfrentamos problemas complejos que
requieren soluciones creativas
en la medida en que generemos
experiencias que nos ayuden a tener
hallazgos para saber cómo hacer mejores
las cosas como ser más profesionales
como aumentar la calidad de un producto
de un servicio de nuestro quehacer
reinventarnos en nuestro trabajo en la
forma en que somos amigos que somos
novios o novias y que somos padres o
madres de familia y aprender cómo lo
hace un águila al momento de volar claro
que habrá fracasos pero las soluciones
creativas no se dan de un brinco a otro
hay que construirlas y ser leales a
estas convicciones
por lo tanto
esta experiencia de la cual habló que es
lo más rico para poder ir concretando
tus sueños en primer lugar se compone de
un compromiso un compromiso que es
permanente que es duradero un compromiso
que empieza contigo y que se da
necesariamente en los demás no podemos
entender al liderazgo como una suma de
cualidades o atributos como si fuera un
checklist a conseguir el liderazgo emana
de estos principios y de estos criterios
que se fundan en compromisos que no se
quedan en la persona sino que se
encuentran en el otro para que hay una
experiencia que se puede dar o dentro de
un salón de clases o liderando algún
proyecto social o emprendiendo algún
negocio o cuidando el medio ambiente
participando de alguna iniciativa o de
alguna campaña este compromiso es
duradero y esto es suficiente para con
una experiencia nos permita solucionar
problemas
que sean complejos y dar por lo tanto
soluciones creativas no no sólo
suficiente el compromiso requerimos de
colaboración
una colaboración que nos lleve a
encontrar más aquello que nos une que
nos identifica que aquello que nos
divide la colaboración es un aspecto
fundamental en nuestros días en la
medida en que lo hagamos la consecución
de nuestros objetivos se podrá tener en
otras palabras no hay líderes que
caminen solos
el compromiso la colaboración y
finalmente la reflexión es un aspecto
fundamental ya qué me refiero con la
reflexión con la capacidad que tenemos
para ver al interior de nosotros para
darnos cuenta en que tenemos que mejorar
que tenemos que compartir
y este ciclo virtuoso de las ideas vaya
permitiendo en nosotros tener los
atributos de un verdadero liderazgo
insisto como una decisión fundamental de
servir al otro luego entonces una
experiencia significativa
no es lo más relevante la experiencia
significativa fue un medio para
conseguir algo mayor este para que le
llamamos un liderazgo transformador por
lo tanto un líder transformador que
quiere cambiar su entorno debe tener
rasgos fundamentales debe tener un
espíritu que le ayude a transformar
estas realidades de cara a un compromiso
mayor a una esperanza compartida de lo
que es bueno para mí también será bueno
para ti
saber
que esta perspectiva de bien común no
solo nos ayuda a hermanar un concepto de
que somos un hombre humanidad de que
tenemos una aldea común sino también
retos compartidos y es precisamente ahí
donde requerimos profesionales que sean
capaces que sean competentes la alta
preparación en nuestros días es
fundamental para que entonces podamos
cambiar estas problemáticas y
transformarlas en soluciones pero para
ello se requiere un sentido humanista
donde la persona siempre esté al centro
y entonces entendamos esta lógica del
servicio para con el otro
finalmente
quisiera invitarte a que tengas una
mirada a tu interior a que generes este
compromiso y si alguno se quedó con la
duda de cuáles son mis sueños vaya que
esos sueños maduraron al punto de
reconocer que lo importante no era un
logro o un objetivo
sino saber que hoy en lo personal
tengo una bella familia con tres
pequeñas que son mi motivación del día a
día y que si bien no soy un futbolista
como de niño lo pensé hacer he
encontrado que mi vocación de servicio
consiste en esto en verme con amigos con
compañeros con colaboradores
compartiendo sueños de tener una
sociedad que sea más humana que sea más
justa
donde se privilegian los los derechos de
la persona y luego entonces entender que
el liderazgo transformador ante todo es
una disposición a servir muchas gracias
[Aplausos]